I need to preface today's episode by
saying it's very different from my usual
content it's strictly political before
you accuse me of partisanship be aware
that I'm disgusted with both major
political parties the way both Democrats
and Republicans have handled the
coronavirus crisis and governing in
general has been incredibly damaging if
this type of content doesn't interest
you feel free not to watch I'll probably
be back to my usual content next week
but if you're an American of working-age
please consider watching this video it
might be the most important one I ever
make thank you
and again when you have 15 people and
the 15 within a couple of days is going
to be down to close to zero that's a
pretty good job we've done today
financial markets suffered historic
losses the Dow falling almost 3,000
points that is the biggest one-day point
drop of all time
concerns are growing about the health
systems ability to handle the peak of
the crisis with beds filling up and
critical supplies dwindling if you can't
afford a payment because you've been
laid off due to coronavirus now is the
time to start making phone calls for US
senators including Intelligence
Committee Chair Richard burr reportedly
sold stock before coronavirus fear sent
the markets plunging shortly after that
tweet that I just noted you sold over a
million dollars in stocks in your own
personal portfolio before the market
went down were you trading on inside
information about what was coming he
dumped his shares in hotel stocks so he
wouldn't lose money and then he stayed
silent now the pressure is really on to
seal this deal and vote with the hopes
that all this money will help convince
hard-hit businesses to keep their
workers on there are 500,000 McDonald's
workers just like me that have to go to
work whether sick or well because we
have no paid sick leave a letter just
sent out by United CEO president and
union leaders basically say they want to
deal by the end of March or payroll cuts
will have to happen for things like
every day we learn about a new celebrity
over a new professional athlete that got
tested and yet my heart I can't get
results on my patient I've been swapping
people for about one week
and I still haven't gotten a result yet
it is incomprehensible and unspeakable
that corporations now are taking
advantage of this crisis in order to get
tax breaks and subsidies that have
nothing to do with the corona virus and
the Congress must be very clear no tax
breaks no subsidies to these
corporations a hundred eighteen years
ago a man who would go on to run for
president from a prison cell said the
cheapest commodity on earth today is
human flesh and blood to make a profit
at the expense of human life is the
central controlling motive of the
capitalist system today over a century
later that statement has never rung more
true Eugene V Debs was a socialist
living in a time when America still had
an active Socialist Party and this line
came from an impromptu speech at the
Butte Auditorium in Montana after being
encouraged by local workers to say a few
words Deb's went on to speak for over
two hours having only planned to stop in
Butte for the day and with no intention
of delivering a speech the locals only
received three hours notice that Deb's
was going to speak the auditorium was
filled to capacity with many late comers
content to stand Deb spoke of the plight
of the working class the nature of class
struggle between those who owned the
factories and those who operate them he
spoke of the value of human life and the
security and dignity every American
deserved as a right he received a
standing ovation the problems of today
are no different from the problems of
Deb's his time they've persisted ever
since
but as America seems to lurch towards a
crisis point all the wealth concentrated
in the hands of a few as the masses lose
their livelihoods in the face of a
pandemic we lacked the understanding of
1902
since that time through conscious action
by those in power the language of class
struggle has been repressed and forced
out of the public conversation we now
live in a time of consensus America is
the greatest nation on earth we've
reached the end of history capitalism
has been vindicated as the sole
successful economic model but deep down
most of us know that's not true
we don't feel successful we're less
well-off than our parents
most of us will never be able to buy a
house or a four
the cost of raising children other
nations look at us with derision or pity
to understand this moment and how we got
here we need to understand the language
of class struggle and acknowledge the
fact that the system is rigged against
those who actually do the work before we
get to the heart of the matter we need
to set the stage
the average American life has changed
dramatically in the past 30 or 40 years
in 1987 the average American could
expect to be able to pay for the
entirety of their four-year college
education on a minimum-wage part-time
salary according to one study the
average combined cost of tuition room
and board across two thousand three
hundred twelve public and private
universities in the US was thirty nine
thousand six hundred forty three dollars
adjusted for inflation let's do some
math all of these numbers will be
adjusted for inflation we'll take a
fairly affordable school say the
University of Central Florida the
four-year price for this particular
school in 1987 was thirty-three thousand
one hundred dollars the minimum wage in
1987 was $7.00 and $0.19 if the student
worked 20 hours per week and put all of
that money towards paying for their
education they could cover a hundred and
6.5 percent of the cost and graduate
with zero student debt fast forward to
2016 and the numbers look very different
the minimum wage is almost exactly the
same
725 versus 719 but over the 30 years the
cost of a four-year degree from the
University of Central Florida rose to 61
thousand eight hundred seventy two
dollars that's an increase of 87 percent
a student working 20 hours per week at
minimum wage in 2016 could only cover
sixty eight point two percent of the
cost and would graduate with almost
twenty thousand dollars in student debt
and these numbers are for a relatively
affordable school what happens when we
pick a more expensive school let's look
at Samford University a little private
school in Birmingham Alabama in 1987 a
four-year degree from Sanford cost fifty
six thousand five hundred nineteen
dollars a student making minimum wage in
1987 would only be able to cover sixty
two point four percent of the total cost
and would graduate with twenty-one
thousand two hundred eighty dollars in
student debt fast forward to 2016 and
the price of a four-year degree from
Sanford had jumped to a hundred sixty
thousand six hundred sixty dollars
that's an increase of a hundred eighty
four percent a student working part-time
in 2016 could only cover twenty six
point three percent of the cost of their
education leaving
them with a hundred eighteen thousand
four hundred thirty-six dollars in
student debt now in this case both
students graduate with loans to pay off
let's do the math on those the average
salary for an early career
college-educated worker was forty-nine
thousand four hundred six dollars in
nineteen eighty seven and fifty thousand
five hundred fifty six dollars in twenty
sixteen
sidenote I and all of my friends would
have loved to find a fifty thousand
dollar job right out of school but I
digress
let's assume both students set aside 10%
of their salary each year to pay towards
their debt and their salary increases by
three percent annually the student in
nineteen eighty seven would be able to
pay off their loans in five years three
months the student in 2016 will likely
never be able to pay off their loan
unless their salary increases
dramatically because the interest owed
would outpace monthly payments the
disparity is even more dramatic if we go
back further in 1968 the minimum wage
was a dollar sixty adjusted for
inflation that's eleven dollars and
seventy six cents the bottom line is
that while cost of everything from
education to housing to groceries and
prescription drugs have all skyrocketed
the wages of workers have remained the
same or gotten worse today the younger
generations live lives defined by
precarity Millennials graduated from
school with mountains of debt entered a
workforce that wasn't hiring or wasn't
offering full-time or benefits many
jumped on new solutions like gig economy
jobs driving for uber or lyft delivering
for any number of delivery companies or
returning to freelance work to pay the
bills and hoping for a steady job to
become available that nine-to-five job
that our parents hated has become a
dream for many young workers and one
that seems increasingly unattainable as
business is outsourced to increase
profits and keep workers just under
full-time so they don't have to provide
benefits like health insurance these
factors have combined to create an
entire generation of young people who
live paycheck to paycheck and are
routinely mocked by older folks who
don't realize just how much has changed
over the last few decades nor do they
seem to realize that the oldest
Millennials are now 40 years old and
we're about to see a whole new
generation enter this rigged economy the
defining moments of the average
Millennials life have been 9/11 the
financial crash of 2008 and now the
coronavirus economic crisis we've seen
none of the promised land that our
parents remember and yet people always
say the economy is doing great and we
see those at the very top at billions -
their net worth every
year and now with the world's largest
and wealthiest superpower on the brink
of collapse it's unsurprising that
people are beginning to ask why this is
happening let's return to the concept of
class struggle there are two overarching
classes in any given society the owner
class or capital and the working class
or labor workers sell their labor and
their time to owners for a wage owners
do not work for a wage instead they own
the means by which capital money is
produced that could be a factory or a
skyscraper or hotel things that need
workers to operate in a nutshell your
goal as a worker and your bosses goal as
an owner are diametrically opposed you
want to spend as little time working for
the greatest wage possible so you have
time to enjoy the fruits of your labor
with your friends and family your boss
wants to get as much work out of you for
as little money as possible to maximize
profits these goals are in conflict this
is the nature of class struggle the
notion of the middle class is largely a
construct to divide the working
population if you work for a wage that
is if you sell your time and labor to
someone else
whether you make fifteen thousand
dollars per year or a hundred fifty
thousand dollars per year you are
working class this will be important
later but for now let's turn to some
things I think everyone can agree upon
if you asked me to sum up the American
dream it would look something like this
three core tenets if you work 40 hours
per week in America you should be able
to afford a home in the city in which
you work the essentials of everyday life
and be able to put a little bit away in
savings one full-time job should be
enough second if you live in America you
should not go bankrupt paying a medical
bill all Americans should be able to see
a doctor when they need to finally
everyone should pay their fair share in
taxes corporations should not be able to
dodge taxes nor should they be able to
buy politicians I think everyone can get
behind these three basic human ideals
just common sense and decency modern day
American capitalism is no longer
compatible with these ideals if you
don't believe me let's look at what
rampant late-stage capitalism has
created
according to the federal reserve's
report on the economic well-being of US
households in 2017 forty percent of
Americans can't afford a surprise four
hundred dollar expense which is a
challenge in a pandemic because an
ambulance ride in America will cost you
more than twice that amount not to
mention the treatment the federal
minimum wage hasn't been adjusted for
inflation in over ten years America is
the only first world country not to
guarantee paid parental leave
life-saving drugs in America often cost
ten times what they cost in other
countries for example in Canada one vial
of insulin cost thirty two dollars in
the United States the same drug from the
same factory cost three hundred dollars
and that's not even an extreme example
take the HIV drug Truvada in australia
it cost just eight dollars in the United
States
it costs two thousand dollars despite US
taxpayers footing the bill for its
development it was estimated that five
hundred thousand people will go bankrupt
from medical expenses this year that was
before the corona virus epidemic now we
have no idea and most people don't even
want to think about it
wealth inequality is at its worst point
in a hundred years with the top
one-tenth of 1% owning the same amount
of wealth as the bottom 90% in 2018 for
the first time in history the richest
400 families paid a lower tax rate than
the bottom 50% so Mike Bloomberg the guy
who just spent a billion dollars on a
disastrous bid for the Democratic
nomination paid a lower tax rate than
his secretary for those of you thinking
so what a smaller percent of a bigger
number is still more money say you've
got $100 and I've got a million dollars
I've got all my needs covered easily so
taking say 20% wouldn't make a
difference to me 20% of your hundred
dollars could be the difference between
covering groceries and bills or not and
while individual greed is reprehensible
what we see from corporations is even
worse in 2018 Amazon paid zero dollars
in federal taxes on eleven point two
billion dollars in profit that is
obscene so what are those in power doing
to fix these problems
[Music]
as Congress is dealing with the brutal
economic fallout from the crisis reports
that at least two senators sold off
stocks after receiving official
coronavirus briefings before the markets
tanked there's a massive economic
stimulus package that's being crafted
this is a part of it it could also
include roughly 50 billion dollars in
assistance for Airlines what Mitch
McConnell and the Republicans in the
Senate just presented was just a package
of corporate sweeteners to hand a blank
check to trump and venusian that is
secret that we won't even know who
they're doling money out to and and then
they're just slapping the name
coronavirus on top of it but if you're
going to pass an eviction of a mortgage
moratorium without also passing a rent
moratorium what you are doing is that
you are providing relief to people
largely at least of the city of New York
based on their class and that you're
providing higher relief to people who
are land owners or landlords now stops
did briefly very briefly move off their
lows today when the Federal Reserve
announced they would pump 1 trillion
dollars of liquidity into the market to
try to calm the market but by the looks
of things and with the dow down over
2,000 points today it looks like that
didn't work you won't be surprised to
learn that the powerful are doing what
they always do trying their best to keep
it the rest of us be damned they're
considering bailouts for industries like
the airlines who spent 96% of the past
decades cash flow on buybacks if you
don't understand what stock buybacks are
here's a quick rundown when a company
has cash on hand they often buy back
their own shares from shareholders and
take them off the market
this makes the remaining shares appear
more valuable this practice
disproportionately benefits executives
whose compensation comes largely in the
form of stock options as opposed to a
traditional salary that's why when you
see a CEO like dave calhoun of Boeing
declared that he won't be taking a
salary this year
you should look more closely most
executive compensation comes from stock
options and other bonuses when Goldman
Sachs was bailed out they awarded their
executives record bonuses for going a
salary is just a show to appear
magnanimous if Boeing gets a bailout
they will do the same thing
every other major corporation does they
will buy back stocks and pad the bank
accounts of their executives at the
expense of taxpayers that's our money
and we will not see any benefit or
gratitude from them remember they spent
96% of the past decades cash flow on
buybacks they'll do it again Boeing is
currently asking for sixty billion
dollars in federal assistance but wait a
minute where was their emergency fund
maybe they should cut out their daily
Starbucks and avocado toast if they want
to save money see what I did there the
workers are expected to have three
months of expenses saved up or risk
being lectured by the rich on financial
responsibility but a couple of weeks of
bad business and now giant corporations
led by multimillionaires are crying for
help it's not just the airlines either
all of the major cruise lines are
calling for bailouts - but the thing
about getting help from the US
government is that you really should
operate as a US business but many cruise
lines operate under foreign flags to
dodge US taxes these include Disney
registered in the Bahamas celebrity in
Malta and Carnival in Panama the Absolut
nerve of these companies whose CEOs haul
in millions of dollars in profits in no
small part because of their tax evasion
in asking the American people to bail
them out but here we get to an
interesting idea
if the Cruise Lines and the airline's
two major contributors to climate change
are on the brink of collapse maybe we
should let them fail or if we do decide
to save them they need to give up the
keys nationalize the industries that
refuse to use their money responsibly
we've been told time and time again that
we don't have the money to transition to
a green economy and yet we're inevitably
going to spend billions bailing out some
of the worst offenders in the climate
crisis we have an opportunity to stop
this but if we're being honest we should
at least expect to see the government
cave and bail out the airlines watch
what happens their executives will make
a lot of money but on the topic of huge
sums of money let's talk about the
attempt to save a spiraling stock market
the Fed pumped 1.5 trillion dollars in
short-term loans into the stock market
hoping to stop the bleeding and keep
investors from losing their minds 1.5
trillion dollars and no one batted an
eye
this is particularly egregious when you
realize that the richest 10% of people
own 90% of all stocks funny to think
that anytime a proposal to help them
already comes along say universal
healthcare or student loan forgiveness
there's a whole lot of pearl clutching
and shouting about how we can't afford
it
despite the mountains of evidence that
show these programs would benefit the
economy but when the wealthy and
powerful wants something sure what the
hell here's one and a half trillion
dollars that might temporarily stop the
sell-off and guess what it's not working
why because the wealthy people who own
the companies don't create value their
workers do when there's no labor keeping
the companies running everything falls
apart but while we're on the topic of
the stock market let's talk about
insider trading that day he dumped up to
1.7 million dollars in stocks and 33
separate transactions BER bought nothing
that day was a flurry of selling on
January 24th he attended a closed-door
briefing on the Chinese coronavirus he
was delivered by dr. Anthony foul he and
the head of the CDC apparently what Burr
heard they're spooked him Burr hid what
he knew about the corona virus threat
and then lied about it at length to the
nation for a public servant it's pretty
hard to imagine many things more immoral
than doing this Richard burr had
critical information that might have
helped the people he is sworn to protect
but he hid that information and helped
only himself instead of sounding the
alarm alerting the country goading the
government into action as an ethical
person would have done Bertold easy lies
that in the end may have killed people
you know you've done something appalling
when Tucker Carlson turns on you what
Leffler and burr did is truly nauseating
they withheld information about the
severity of the coming crisis and they
profited from it these people have blood
on their hands but the thing is they're
just playing the game of capitalism they
saw an opportunity to make money and
they took it but as I'm writing the
script for this video on Tuesday March
24th we're beginning to see something
even more sadistic we have to get back
to work
our people want to work they want to go
back they have to go back let's get back
to work let's get back to living let's
be smart about it
and those of us who are 70 plus will
take care of ourselves but don't
sacrifice the country don't do that
don't ruin so you're basically saying
that this disease could take your life
but that's not the scariest thing to you
there's something that would be worse
than dying
yeah you know is the Cure worse than the
disease because you're talking about
shutting down the world economy but we
cannot let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself we're not gonna let the
Cure be worse than the problem really it
was inevitable that we'd reached this
point as our economy tanks because we
botched the response to the coronavirus
the ultra-wealthy would need to find a
way to fix it their solution human
sacrifice look at this chart we have the
worst trajectory line we've been hearing
a lot of talk about flattening the curve
referring to keeping the number of cases
below the capacity for the healthcare
system but if the owner class decides to
tell everybody to go back to work guess
what's going to happen we're not going
to flatten the curve we're going to kill
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people the act of going on TV and
suggesting that grandparents should be
willing to die for the sake of the
economy and their grandchildren is pure
evil plain and simple
let's look at the two options we have
option 1 follow the lead of other more
ethical nations and do everything in our
power to flatten the curve keep our
people safe and cover their expenses for
the duration of the crisis or option to
condemn millions to die because some
billionaire [ __ ] can't stand to lose
a few dollars one option is morally
right and the other is capitalism guess
which one will win by the time this
video is uploaded I bet we'll have our
answer
in the midst of all this talk about hard
truths and sacrifice and greater good
there's one group of people who are
revealing themselves to be absolute
parasites so if you own 2030 rental
houses and a lot of people start losing
their jobs what do you think that's
gonna do to you they're not gonna be
able make payment which means you're
gonna have to make it as you have an
extra expense evicting them you're gonna
have more vacancy loss more expenses
more care costs trying to fix properly
back up to get it nice to rent out again
let's get one thing straight being a
landlord is not a job the number of
entitled landlords taking to Twitter to
rant is staggering saying things like it
is a job I have to install lights or I
have to decorate the place that's not a
job that's part of being a homeowner and
no one forced you to buy additional
homes when the first of the month rolls
around and these Vipers start to
ending rent that people can no longer
pay because their jobs are shut down
what happens
massive Ixion's in the middle of a
global pandemic don't think for a second
most landlords will be lenient they've
already shown that they don't care when
they say to you tough luck
I have a mortgage to pay what they're
really saying is you have a mortgage to
pay for me being a landlord is not a job
these people buy up all the properties
and hold them hostage they are part of
the problem finally let's talk about the
myth of the philanthropic billionaire
we've all heard the ultra-wealthy say
things like we shouldn't be taxed
because billions of dollars in the hands
of a good person is more useful to
society than in the hands of the
government you should have been
skeptical of this claim in the first
place but the pandemic has made it
abundantly clear that there's no such
thing as a good billionaire look at some
of the largest corporations McDonald's
Amazon Walmart these companies make
billions in profits and yet their
workers are some of the worst
compensated and even in the face of a
deadly disease they're expected to come
into work and they're not guaranteed
paid sick leave some companies even have
the nerve to ask employees to donate
their sick days to affected co-workers
instead of just giving everyone
guaranteed leave but finally finally
we're seeing normal people begin to
fight back on March 23rd Amazon gave in
to pressure from a small crew of workers
at D CH 1 in Chicago they had been
inspired by Sacramento Amazon workers
starting a petition to demand paid time
off walking off the job and demanding a
meeting with the regional manager and so
they did the same thing they organized
their co-workers and three crews from 3
different shifts handed in copies of the
petition to the boss at company meetings
and you know what happened they won they
took on the richest man on the planet
and they won all Amazon employees are
now entitled to paid time off that's
what happens when the workers realize
that they have real power when they work
together we're beginning to see similar
actions from sanitation workers with
Pittsburgh garbage collectors refusing
to pick up trash without getting
adequate protection and hazard pay
we're seeing renters who won't be able
to pay their bills on the 1st of the
month
stand up to merciless landlords renters
are hanging white sheets outside their
windows as a sign of solidarity with the
millions of others pressing for a
national rent strike these are good
things we need more of them
so let's recap the current state of
affairs
we're projected to experience the worst
unemployment in US history in the middle
of a global pandemic yet our ability to
see a doctor is tied to our employment
those in power are bickering over relief
legislation while we're just days away
from millions being unable to afford
their rent payments opportunists like
Senator Leffler are posting pictures of
them working hard when they've just been
caught insider trading and literally
profiting off the death of their fellow
Americans we've seen billionaires and
the world's wealthiest corporations try
to save a few bucks by refusing to take
care of their employees
despite the rich always saying the money
does more good in the hands of
philanthropic billionaires that is
obviously a lie they hoard their wealth
and leave millions to die the government
dumped one-and-a-half trillion into the
stock market like it was nothing
remember that the next time they say
something is too expensive they're lying
at least this pandemic has made some
things abundantly clear when your boss
said your job couldn't be done from home
they were lying when University said a
class couldn't be taught online they
were lying when those in power say
universal health care is too expensive
they're lying
every time they say a beneficial program
is too expensive
they're lying that forgiving student
loan debt is impossible that raising
wages is too difficult that affordable
housing is unreasonable all lies
those at the levers of power always use
that power to keep it they will never
give up any of that power without a
struggle as we saw with Amazon so what
can we do if power is so entrenched in
the hands of the few what can normal
people do the pandemic has made one more
thing clear the economy doesn't function
without workers it falls apart in a week
without the cashiers stalkers drivers
and countless others rich people love to
deride as lazy the pandemic has proven
that it's the workers who create value
not the owners who do nothing there is
power in labor if the millions at the
bottom stand up and say enough is enough
you work for us now we'll see some real
changes unite in solidarity with your
fellow workers and press your demands
capitalism is the root of all of today's
evils it cannot solve the problems it
creates those in power will listen to
the rest of us if we can organize and
really pressure them to enact our
demands whether you make fifteen
thousand dollars a year or a hundred
fifty thousand if you sell your labor
and hours of your life for a wage
you are working-class that should be a
mark of pride because it's the
working-class that keeps this country
running the parasites at the very top
don't care if you die they would rather
kill millions of Americans than lose a
single percent of their wealth it's time
to remember the language of class
struggle and fight for dignity and a
livable future if you'd like to learn
more about any of the topics discussed
in this video
I've left links in the description take
the time to educate yourself about the
things that matter we have a future to
win and we need everybody to do their
part thank you for watching